[Musik]
egal was ich Andreas innerhalb von
stellte sein Leben auf den Kopf der
ehemalige Banker fiel 2016 in Norwegen
nochmals ganz von vorne an
das Beste
[Musik]
fast ein halbes Leben arbeitete Andreas
inalban als Jurist und Banker an der
Zürcher Bahnhofstraße
sein Herz aber gehörte schon immer den
Hunden
haben
[Musik]
bietet mit seinen 60 Huskys
schlittenhundefahrten für Touristen an
aber das Geschäft harzt er kämpft um
seine Existenz
[Musik]
für andere für andere Ideen hat merkt ja
man muss ja gar nicht so läuft wie die
meisten Mainstream mäßig macht
hauptsächlich ein besonderer
seine Familie ist neben seinen Hunden
das Wichtigste im Leben von Andreas in
Heilbronn aus seiner geschiedenen Ehe
hat er drei Kinder
die älteste Tochter siri ist zu Besuch
sie lebte nach dem Matura zwei Jahre bei
ihrem Vater in Norwegen mittlerweile
studiert sie akronomie an der ETA
[Musik]
und das ist lief vor drei Monaten ist
Andreas nochmals Vater geworden
mit 53 beginnt er auch Familie nochmals
von vorne zusammen mit seiner Partnerin
Petra
aber machen
komplett
ist
schaffen
funktioniert nicht
kennengelernt hat Andreas in alban seine
Partnerin Petra Suter hier in Norwegen
2019 arbeitete sie bei ihm als
freiwillige Helferin sie verliebten sich
und wohnen heute auf ihre eigenen Farm
abgelegen in der Provinz hitmark
zuerst probierte in Album sein Geld
hauptsächlich mit Nutztieren zu
verdienen
[Musik]
aber ein extrem trockener Sommer zwang
ihn umzudenken und voll auf die Hunde zu
setzen dann kam die Pandemie das
Ersparte war irgendwann aufgebraucht
hast du Hunger
warum stellen
um über die Runden zu kommen bauten sie
sich noch ein zweites Standbein auf
zusammen mit zwei anderen Familien haben
sie eine bereits bestehende und in der
husky-szene bekannte rennschlittenmarke
übernommen die gelernte Schreinerin und
zimmerin Petra Sutter baut nun Schlitten
für Hunde rennen
im letzten Winter
in der ehemaliger
produziert
arbeiten
und dann hoffe ich natürlich dass ich
dann
selber
aber auch das Geschäft mit den
Rennschlitten läuft nicht nach Plan es
gibt Material Lieferschwierigkeiten
wegen Corona und den Krieg in der
Ukraine
also
gewesen
und wenn man dann quasi selber sich
selbstständig macht und merkt
ja
ganz einfach
babyschlitten sind so alle Renner
Verwaltung
eigentlich langfristig Probleme mit mit
der Zulieferung dass ich jetzt wieder
erschwerend dazu suche aber ich bin
zuversichtlicher wesentlich
zuversichtlicher wie jetzt
dass das gut kommt
[Musik]
der 54-Jährige hatte Pech mit dem
Zeitpunkt seine Auswanderung
von Anfang an war er mit Problemen
konfrontiert die er nicht selber
verursacht hatte
sein altes Leben wünscht er sich aber
nicht zurück
[Musik]
schwierig
Schäfer erwachsen der Unzufriedenheit
sie mit dem Job ja vor 80%
wirklich unbefriedigend dass ich jetzt
für mich es gibt andere oder das
Niederösterreich und dann ja entschieden
wenn nichts machen Ende Monat gar nicht
und die visionssicherheit ist der neue
Triebfeder weiterzumachen und für seinen
Traum zu kämpfen
nach unkonventionellen Lösungen zu
suchen und diese zu finden fernab seiner
neuen Heimat
[Musik]
eine Alb im Bündnerland Andreas in
albonn arbeitet bereits den dritten
Sommer als schafherd um sich das Leben
im hohen Norden leisten zu kennen
die Hütehunde hatte aus Norwegen
mitgebracht
wie viel das da hinten sind weiß ich
auch nicht aber jetzt gehen wir weiter
unterstützt wird er von einer
freiwilligen Helferin
die Arbeit mit Hund und Herdentieren hat
sich der Ex-Banker selbst beigebracht
und Kelly gehorcht aufs Wort
Border Collie kelly hat die Schafe im
Griff
die Junghunde sind noch in Ausbildung
und müssen zur Sicherheit an der Leine
bleiben
jetzt im Job im Büro
in dem Sinn
[Musik]
wird es plötzlich gefährlich
eine Gruppe Schafe verirrt sich auf
einen Felsvorsprung und droht
abzustürzen
die Schafe sind wieder auf sicherem
Terrain
wieder scharf hat jetzt die letzten
zwei Jahre hier oben
mir kommt das ist scharf abgestürzt ist
wo man
auf sich
aber wenn jetzt ein Hund hat gewonnen
und dann wäre vielleicht ein paar
wunderbar
[Musik]
die Arbeit in den Bündner Bergen ist aus
einer Not heraus geboren und anstrengend
aber Andreas
[Musik]
auch wenn er für mehrere Monate von
seiner Familie in Norwegen getrennt ist
nein dass ich nicht kommen
[Musik]
zwei Wochen Zeit Tage etc
getrennt sind
ich sage wenn du bisschen telefonieren
Petra Suter hat in Norwegen Helfer die
sie bei der Arbeit mit den Hunden und
den farmtieren unterstützen
Andreas in Heilbronn machte früher
Karriere als Bianca jährlicher Bonus
inklusive heute lebte ein einfacheres
Leben
arbeiten aber ja jetzt Ziel auf das
schaffen wir momentan
aber wie gesagt mir passt es das voll
und ganz eigentlich
Tourismus vielleicht Halbstamm hier
es soll hier sein letzter altsommer sein
er ist zuversichtlich dass er künftig in
Norwegen genug verdient
[Musik]
zurück im norwegischen Winter Hund
panderus hat es sich bei der
Freiwilligen Helferin Susanna und
Tochter Sirin bequem gemacht
die beiden fahren mit Andreas in albonn
und den Hunden in die größte Skiregion
des Landes nach triese das ist bereits
taut Mitte März ist ungewöhnlich und
gefällt Andreas gar nicht er mag lieber
lange und kalte Winter natürlich oder
heute Dokument für Norwegen
schöne enorm schöne
norwegische Familie normal im Winter bei
minus 20 Grad
und sitzen aufmachen des Führer und den
grillieren
vorstellbar für diese Schweiz
der Startplatz für die
hundeschlittenturen ist im Wald
in der Hauptsaison wohnt Andreas
innerbonn auf einem nahe gelegenen
Campingplatz um sich die zweistündige
Anfahrt zu sparen
das Geschäft läuft endlich besser die
Touristen sind nach der Pandemie wieder
zurück die Schlittenhunde Crew ist mit
über 20 Hunden und fünf Schlitten am
Start
die verschiedenen Hundeteams
zusammenzustellen ist eine knifflige
Angelegenheit
der neue niedrig hier ein gemütlicher
Feuerplatz darf auch nicht fehlen
Michelle
Marius hallo
sonst würdest du in deinen Schuhen nicht
überleben
[Gelächter]
in den Wald gehen da sind die Hunde
lasst uns gehen
das ist die gefährlichste Stelle hoffe
ich zumindest
[Musik]
eine Rundtour mit den Hunden durch den
Wald dauert 40 Minuten und kostet pro
Person rund 175 Franken
macht Spaß so
weil die Gäste selbst ein Hundegespann
lenken dürfen braucht es eine gründliche
Einführung was willst du über
Schlittenhunde
überhaupt nichts
dann dauert meine Einführung wohl eine
Stunde länger
der big break die große Bremse braucht
ihr am Start der Fahrer muss mit beiden
Beinen auf dieser Bremse stehen hier
gebt den Hunden das Kommando halt doch
was ihr sagt ist den ziemlich egal
deshalb müsst ihr gleichzeitig auf die
Bremse stehen
für die Gäste scheint alles klar zu sein
halt Bremsen und die Hand heben damit
der hinter euch sieht dass er auch
bremsen muss
und gleichzeitig Bremsen das Kommando um
wieder loszufahren ist okay
die Hunde kennen es kaum erwarten bis es
endlich losgeht
[Musik]
Schlittenhunde lieben nichts mehr als zu
laufen in albons Hunde rennen pro Jahr
bis zu 5000 km okay
der Walliser wurde von mehreren Krisen
ausgebremst jetzt geht es endlich nur
noch in eine Richtung vorwärts
geht's euch hier noch kurz gespannt
und die Gäste
offenbar gibt es weiter hinten ein
Problem
[Applaus]
ja sind die Burschen
City guys
hinfallen und wieder aufstehen das passt
auch zum Leben von Andreas innerbonn in
Norwegen
[Musik]
er änderte sein Leben grundlegend
machte sein Hobby zum Beruf
strauchelte
und kommt jetzt sieben Jahre nach seiner
Auswanderung endlich wieder so richtig
auf die Beine
[Gelächter]
neben den Rundtouren durch den Wald
macht der Hundeschlittenführer auch
Tagestouren ins Welt in die magischen
runden Hügel von Siemens Marker
[Musik]
solche Touren machen den ehemaligen
Banker glücklich genau dafür hat er
gekämpft
und dann kommen Andreas
seine wahre Leidenschaft sind
Hundeschlittenrennen insbesondere in der
Disziplin skiurin war er sehr
erfolgreich und wurde sogar
Vize-Weltmeister
endlich kann Andreas in alban die
Früchte seiner Arbeit ernten
so viel trainiert wie die letzten zwei
Jahren
[Musik]
hier auf der norwegischen Alb macht die
Gruppe eine Mittagspause
lebst du noch
schnell ist ein lauschiges Plätzchen
unter einem Baum entdeckt doch ganz so
einsam und ruhig bleibt es nicht lange
[Musik]
Familie sucht sich für ihr Picknick
ausgerechnet den gleichen Baum aus
ich habe auch schon am viel Mülltrennen
teilgenommen und dieser Hund hat dieses
Rennen 2022 gewonnen das ist eine aus
unserer Zucht
wo schau mal der schwarze hat das Film
ins gewonnen
der Ex-Banker musste seit seiner
Auswanderung auf vieles verzichten und
trotzdem
und das wenigstens Fixkosten definitiv
das Glück liegt für Andreas in alban
nicht auf dem Bürostuhl sondern auf dem
Hundeschlitten
inzwischen kann der 54-Jährige von
seinen Hunden und den Rennschlitten
Leben er hat sein Ziel erreicht und das
nächste hat er bereits in Sichtweite ein
Hundeschlittenrennen über 500 km